Let's talk about historically how
Muslims behaved as far as mosques and
and whatnot. So, the first thing to keep
in mind is what's a mosque? Do you know
that word? Mosque, you know, we get it
with the m o s q e q u e. That's sort of
a French transliteration of an Arabic
word, mesjid. Okay? So, mosque means
mesjid. And mesjid seged sajjad means to
prostrate. A mesjid is a place where one
prostrates. That's it. So, a mosque is
not a building per se. Historically,
when Muhammad was doing it, they didn't
have buildings. They had maybe huts here
and there that were built over places
that Muhammad that became his mesjid
where he prostrated. But, by nature, a
mesjid, a mosque, is just wherever
Muslims congregate and pray, which is
exactly what they turned London's
Trafalgar Square into, right? A couple
weeks ago. Now, for those who don't
understand the significance of what it
means when Muslims actually congregate
together and engage in mass communal
prayer, does that mean that is that a
supremacist takeover as Timothy and many
others said or is that like, no, we're
just come on, tolerance. We want to
pray. Give us a place to pray.
So, let me give you an interesting
anecdote.
>> [clears throat]
>> One that Muslims are very fond of
sharing
as a way to show you how tolerant they
are. But, in the current context, it's
actually going to prove the opposite
about what we're talking about about,
you know, where a Muslim prays, what
happens to that place. So, in the year
637 after the Muslims conquered
Jerusalem, which was considered
Christian land for centuries at this
point after Constantine the Great and
even before him. But, um
Caliph Omar, so the story goes,
entered into Jerusalem in 637.
And then he was talking to Patriarch
Sophronius. And um basically, Omar said,
I it's time for me to pray.
Now, Patriarch Sophronius, of course,
knowing absolutely nothing about this
new creed, which probably had not even
coalesced at this point into a
meaningful coherent religion, on hearing
that this pagan wants to pray,
he told him, you know, go go pray in the
Holy Sepulchre. Maybe you can even
repent there.
Okay? And then Omar refused.
And he said and he just went to a side
and he prayed somewhere else.
And then when he came back, he said to
the Patriarch Sophronius, he said, do
you know why
um I didn't pray in the Holy Sepulchre?
And the Patriarch said, why?
And Omar said, quote, if I had prayed
inside the church, you would be losing
it and it would have gone from your
hands because after my death, the
Muslims would seize it saying, Omar
prayed here. And this is from a 10th
century the Annals of Nazm al-Jawz Hari.
Now, whether this is apocryphal or not
is not the point. The point is that
Muslims often use this to show you how
tolerant Muslims were that, look, Omar
could have just walked into the Holy
Sepulchre and prayed there and then it
would become a mosque, but he didn't do
that. He's tolerant. But, in the current
context, it really sheds light on how
Muslims transform non-Muslim places into
mosques. Because here it is. He
basically said, Omar said, if I prayed
in your church, that would have made it
a mosque and my followers would have
taken it from you. And I guess what?
That has happened multiple times
historically to Christian churches and
to other non-Muslim temples of worship
historically. And it's not just that, of
course. The interesting point is that
prayers are often seen communal prayers
are often seen as consolidating
conquests. So, if you conquer a
non-Muslim region, the way you
consolidate your absolute control
symbolically is by having communal
prayers by creating a mesjid, right? A
mesque, a mosque there. And there's
again so many examples of this happening
going back to Muhammad. Okay? So, the
Kaaba in Mecca was, of course, a temple
a pagan temple full of idols. And after
he conquered Mecca, he marched in and
smashed all the idols and prayed and it
became a mosque. Now, it's the greatest
mosque for the Muslims. Same thing with
Al-Aqsa Mosque in Jerusalem.
It's built intentionally on what was
Solomon's Temple. They knew that. They
knew that Solomon's Temple and they
built it there. Of course, the the
temple was gone by then, so they didn't
have a chance to destroy it. But, in the
case of the Church of St. John, also in
Jerusalem, a very famous at the time
church, the Umayyad Mosque was built
atop it. How? Well, the Caliph, Caliph
Walid the First, seized the church and
completely destroyed it and cleansed it
and rebuilt it as a mosque. That has
happened on multiple multiple occasions
all throughout history. Now, the most
famous one, of course, which we can look
at is the conquest of the Hagia Sophia,
Holy Wisdom, in Constantinople and how
that became a mosque. And luckily,
unlike all the other anecdotes or
transformation of non-Muslim temples
into mosques, most of the ones I just
mentioned, you know, the Kaaba, even the
St. John Church and Al-Aqsa, these are
in the 7th and 8th century. So, we don't
have copious primary sources to look at
the details. But, we do have a lot for
the sack of Constantinople and the
transformation of Hagia Sophia into a
mosque.
So, let's briefly look into that. As we
know, the famous and we have a lot of
information because it's closer to us in
time. The aforementioned ones are from
the 7th and 8th centuries. Hagia Sophia,
this is 15th century. So, we have a lot
of records. Anyone's interested, I've
copiously recorded them in chapter seven
of Sword and Scimitar. And I'm going to
give you some quotes actually here. This
is where I sourced it from. If you want
the actual citations, they're in the
book in the endnotes. So, on May 29th,
1453, the Ottoman Turks, the Muslims,
finally took and sacked Constantinople
where Hagia Sophia is. And at the time,
Hagia Sophia was about a thousand years
old and it was one of the most glorious
basilicas of Christendom at the time.
So, what did the Muslims do on entering
this, you know, magnificent church?
Well, they engaged in abominations and
rapes and all sorts of things. Here's a
quote. They, quote, engaged in every
kind of vileness within it making of it
a public brothel. On its altars, they
enacted perversions with our women,
virgins, and children including the
Grand Duke's daughter who was quite
beautiful. These are eyewitness
accounts. She was forced to lie on the
great altar of Hagia Sophia with a
crucifix under her head as a way of
mocking her and then gang raped. All
right? This is what they did on the
altar of this church. Okay? Then, they
paraded the Hagia Sophia's crucifix in a
mocking procession throughout the camp
beating drums before it and according to
the source that I'm reading, crucifying
Christ again with spitting and
blasphemies and curses. They placed a
Turkish cap upon his head, the statue of
Christ, and jeeringly cried, behold the
God of the Christians. Okay? All the
other churches in that ancient city were
suffered the same fate. Here's another
quote. The crosses which had been placed
on the roofs or the or the walls of
churches were torn down and trampled.
The Eucharist was hurled to the ground.
Holy icons were stripped of gold, thrown
to the ground, and kicked. Bibles were
stripped of their gold or silver
illuminations before being burned. Icons
were without exception given to the
flames. Patriarchal vestments were
placed on the haunches of dogs. Priestly
garments were placed on horses. All, of
course, in as a way to mock Christianity
and Christians. And then, again, the
quotes continue. Everywhere there was
misfortune. Everyone was touched by pain
when, quote, when Sultan Muhammad
finally made his grand entry in the
city. There were lamentations and
weeping in every house, screaming in the
crossroads, and sorrow in all churches.
The groaning of grown men and the
shrieking of women accompanied by
looting, enslavement, separation, and
mass rape. All right? These are all the
quotes. Again, you can see them in Sword
and Scimitar. Okay? Then, after all
that, came the grand moment to
consolidate Islam's triumph. Like I was
telling you. First, there's the sack and
the rapine and then finally, you get the
the consolidation. Sultan Muhammad,
Mehmet the Second, entered Hagia Sophia,
quote, marveling at the sight. But,
before long, he emulated his namesake,
the Prophet Muhammad, who, as I
mentioned, on entering the Kaaba had
smashed all its idols. So, now Sultan
Muhammad ordered all the destruction of
Hagia Sophia's many crosses, statues,
and icons. And then he himself knocked
over and trampled on the main altar of
of the basilica before ordering a
muezzin to ascend the pulpit and sound
their, quote, detestable prayers. Again,
I'm quoting a contemporary Christian
eyewitness. He continues, then this son
of iniquity, this forerunner of
Antichrist, mounted upon the holy table
to utter forth his own prayers thereby
turning the great church into a heathen
shrine for his God and his Muhammad.
Okay? So, that's what happens where
Muslims pray.
England. All right? And then again, that
account which I gave you, we have such
details simply because it's closer to us
in time. But, I have no doubt the same
exact rituals and worse occurred during
the sack of all the other churches, the
ones I mentioned and all the thousands
in between them over the centuries.
Bring back the
and the righteousness.